the following is a conversation with Jim
Keller legendary microprocessor engineer
who has worked at AMD Apple Tesla and
now Intel he's known for his work on AMD
K 7 K 8 K 12 and Xen microarchitectures
Apple a4 and a5 processors and co-author
of the specification for the x86 64
instruction set and hyper transport
interconnect he's a brilliant first
principles engineer and out-of-the-box
thinker and just an interesting and fun
human being to talk to this is the
artificial intelligence podcast if you
enjoy it subscribe on YouTube give it
five stars an apple podcast follow on
Spotify supported on patreon or simply
connect with me on Twitter Alex Friedman
spelled Fri D ma a.m. I recently started
doing ads at the end of the introduction
I'll do one or two minutes after
introducing the episode and never any
ads in the middle that can break the
flow of the conversation I hope that
works for you and doesn't hurt the
listening experience this show is
presented by cash app the number one
finance I up in the App Store
I personally use cash app to send money
to friends but you can also use it to
buy sell and deposit Bitcoin in just
seconds cash app also has a new
investing feature you can buy fractions
of a stock say $1 worth no matter what
the stock price is brokers services are
provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
I'm excited to be working with cash app
to support one of my favorite
organizations called first best known
for their first robotics and Lego
competitions they educate and inspire
hundreds of thousands of students in
over 110 countries and have a perfect
rating a charity navigator which means
that donated money is used to maximum
effectiveness when you get cash app from
the App Store Google Play and use code
Lex podcast you'll get ten dollars and
cash app will also donate ten dollars to
the first which again is an organization
that I've personally seen inspire girls
and boys the dream of engineering a
better world and now here's my
with Jim Keller what are the differences
in similarities between the human brain
and a computer with the microprocessors
core let's start with a philosophical
question perhaps well since people don't
actually understand how human brains
work I think that's true I think that's
true so it's hard to compare them
computers are you know there's really
two things there's memory and there's
computation right and to date almost all
computer architectures are global memory
which is a thing right and then
computation where you pull data and you
do relatively simple operations on it
and write data back so it's decoupled in
modern in modern computers and you think
in the human brain everything's a mesh a
mess that's combined together what
people observe is there's you know some
number of layers of neurons which have
local and global connections and
information is stored in some
distributed fashion and people build
things called neural networks in
computers where the information is
distributed in some kind of fashion you
know there's a mathematics behind it I
don't know that the understandings that
is super deep the computations we run on
those are straightforward computations I
don't believe anybody has said a neuron
does this computation so to date it's
hard to compare them I would say so
let's get into the basics before we zoom
back out how do you build a computer
from scratch what is a microprocessor
what is it microarchitecture what's an
instruction set architecture maybe even
as far back as what is a transistor so
the special charm of computer
engineering is there's a relatively good
understanding of abstraction layers so
down to bottom you have atoms and atoms
get put together in materials like
silicon or dope silicon or metal and we
build transistors on top of that we
build logic gates
right and in functional units like an
adder or subtractor or an instruction
parsing unit and we assemble those into
you know processing elements modern
computers are built out of you know
probably 10 to 20 locally you know
organic processing elements or coherent
processing elements and then that runs
computer programs right so there's
abstraction layers and then software you
know there's an instruction set you run
and then there's assembly language C C++
Java JavaScript you know there's
abstraction layers you know essentially
from the atom to the data center right
so when you when you build a computer
you know first there's a target like
what's it for look how fast does it have
to be which you know today there's a
whole bunch of metrics about what that
is and then in an organization of you
know a thousand people who build a
computer there's lots of different
disciplines that you have to operate on
does that make sense and so so there's a
bunch of levels abstraction of in in
organizational I can tell and in your
own vision there's a lot of brilliance
that comes in it every one of those
layers some of it is science some was
engineering some of his art what's the
most
if you could pick favorites what's the
most important your favorite layer on
these layers of abstractions where does
the magic enter this hierarchy I don't
really care that's the fun you know I'm
somewhat agnostic to that so I would say
for relatively long periods of time
instruction sets are stable so the x86
instruction said the arm instruction set
what's an instruction set so it says how
do you encode the basic operations load
store multiply add subtract conditional
branch you know there aren't that many
interesting instructions look if you
look at a program and it runs you know
90% of the execution is on 25 opcodes
you know 25 instructions on those are
stable right what does it mean stable
until architecture has been around for
twenty-five years it works it works and
that's because the basics you know or
defined a long time ago right now the
way an old computer ran is you fetched
instructions and you executed them in
order to the load do the ad do the
compare the way a modern computer works
is you fetch large numbers of
instructions say 500 and then you find
the dependency graph between the
instructions and then you you execute in
independent units those little micro
graphs so a modern computer like people
like to say computers should be simple
and clean but it turns out the market
for a simple complete clean slow
computers is zero right we don't sell
any simple clean computers now you can
there's how you build it can be clean
but the computer people want to buy
that's say you know phone or data center
such as a large number of instructions
computes the dependency graph and then
executes it in a way that gets the right
answers and optimizes that graph somehow
yeah they run deeply out of order and
then there's semantics around how memory
ordering works and other things work so
the the computer sort of has a bunch of
bookkeeping tables it says what order
CDs operations finishing or appear to
finish him but to go fast you have to
fetch a lot of instructions and find all
the parallelism now there's a second
kind of computer which we call GPUs
today and I called the difference
there's found parallelism like you have
a program with a lot of dependent
instructions you fetch a bunch and then
you go figure out the dependency graph
and you issues instructions out order
that's because you have one serial
narrative to execute which in fact is
and can be done out of order you call a
narrative yeah well so yeah so humans
think of serial narrative so read read a
book right there's a you know there's
the sends after sentence after sentence
and there's paragraphs
now you could diagram that
imagine you diagrammed it properly and
you said which sentences could be read
in anti order any order without changing
the meaning right but that's a
fascinating question to ask of a book
yeah yeah you could do that right so
some paragraphs could be reordered some
sentences can be reordered you could say
he is tall and smart and X right and it
doesn't matter the order of tall and
smart but if you say is that tall man
who's wearing a red shirt what colors
you know like you can create
dependencies right right and so GPUs on
the other hand run simple programs on
pixels but you're given a million of
them and the first order the screen
you're looking at it doesn't care which
order you do it in so I call that given
parallelism simple narratives around the
large numbers of things where you can
just say it's parallel because you told
me it was so found parallelism where the
narrative is it's sequential but you
discover like little pockets of
parallelism of versus turns out large
pockets of parallelism large so how hard
is it to discuss well how hard is it
that's just transistor count right so
once you crack the problem you say
here's how you fetch ten instructions at
a time here's how you calculated the
dependencies between them here's how you
describe the dependencies here's you
know these are pieces right so once you
describe the dependencies then it's just
a graph sort of it's an algorithm that
finds what is that I'm sure there's a
graph there is the theoretical answer
here that's solved well in general
programs modern programs like human
beings right
how much found parallelism is there and
on that I max what is 10 next mean oh
well you execute it in order vs. yeah
you would get what's called cycles per
instruction and it would be about you
know three instructions three cycles per
instruction because of the latency of
the operations and stuff
and in a modern computer excuse it but
like point to 0.25 cycles per
instruction so it's about with today
fine 10x and there and there's two
things one is the found parallelism in
the narrative right and the other is to
predictability of the narrative right so
certain operations they do a bunch of
calculations and if greater than one do
this else do that that that decision is
predicted in modern computers to high
90% accuracy so branches happen a lot so
imagine you have you have a decision to
make every six instructions which is
about the average right but you want to
fetch five under instructions figure out
the graph and execute them all in
parallel that means you have let's say
if you effect 600 instructions it's
every six you have to fetch you have to
predict ninety-nine out of a hundred
branches correctly for that window to be
effective okay so parallelism you can't
paralyze branches or you can looking
pretty you can what is predict a branch
mean or what open take so imagine you do
a computation over and over you're in a
loop so Wow
and it's greater than one do and you go
through that loop a million times so
every time you look at the branch you
say it's probably still greater than one
he's saying you could do that accurately
very accurately monitoring comes my mind
is blown how the heck did you that wait
a minute
well you want to know this is really sad
20 years ago
yes you simply recorded which way the
branch went last time and predicted the
same thing right okay what's the
accuracy of that 85% so then somebody
said hey let's keep a couple of bits and
have a little counter so and it predicts
one way we count up and then pins so say
you have a three bit counter so you
count up and then count down and if it's
you know you can use the top bit as the
sign bit so you have a sign to bit
number so if it's greater than one you
predict taken and lesson one you predict
not-taken
right or less than zero or whatever the
thing is
and that got us to 92% oh okay I know is
this better
this branch depends on how you got there
so if you came down the code one way
you're talking about Bob and Jane right
and then said is just Bob like Jane
Enoch went one way but if you're talking
about Bob and Jill this Bob like changes
you go a different way
right so that's called history so you
take the history and a counter that's
cool but that's not how anything works
today they use something that looks a
little like a neural network so modern
you take all the execution flows and
then you do basically deep pattern
recognition of how the program is
executing and you do that multiple
different ways and you have something
that chooses what the best result is
there's a little supercomputer inside
the computer that's trying to project
that calculates which way branches go so
the effective window that it's worth
finding grassing gets bigger why was
that gonna make me sad that's amazing
it's amazingly complicated oh well
here's the funny thing so to get to 85%
took a thousand bits to get to 99% takes
tens of megabits
so this is one of those to get the
result you want you know to get from a
window of say 50 instructions to 500 it
took three orders of magnitudes or four
orders of magnitude toward bits now if
you get the prediction of a branch wrong
what happens then what is the pipe you
flush the pipes is just the performance
cost but it gets even better yeah so
we're starting to look at stuff that
says so executed down this path and then
you had two ways to go but far far away
there's something that doesn't matter
which path you went so you miss you took
the wrong path you executed a bunch of
stuff then you had to miss predicting
too backed it up but you remembered all
the results you already calculated some
of those are just fine
look if you read a book and you
misunderstand the paragraph your
understanding is the next paragraph
sometimes is invariance I don't
understand you sometimes it depends on
it and you can kind of anticipate that
invariance yeah well you can keep track
of whether that data changed and so when
you come back to a piece of code should
you calculate it again or do the same
thing okay how much does this is art and
how much of it is science because it
sounds pretty complicated so well how do
you describe a situation so imagine you
come to a point in the road we have to
make a decision right and you have a
bunch of knowledge about which way to go
maybe you have a map so you want to go
is the shortest way or do you want to go
the fastest way or you want to take the
nicest Road so it's just some set of
data so imagine you're doing something
complicated like a building a computer
and there's hundreds of decision points
all with hundreds of possible ways to go
and the ways you pick interacts in a
complicated way right and then you have
to pick the right spot right so those
are there so I don't know yeah avoided
the question you just described do the
Robert Frost poem road less taken I
describe the Robin truss problem which
we do as computer designers it's all
poetry ok great
yeah I don't know how to describe that
because some people are very good at
making those intuitive leaps it seems
like the combinations of things some
people are less good at it but they're
really good at evaluating your
alternatives right and everybody has a
different way to do it and some people
can't make those sleeps but they're
really good at analyzing it so when you
see computers are designed by teams of
people who have very different skill
sets and a good team has lots of
different kinds of people and I suspect
you would describe some of them as
artistic right but not very many
unfortunately or fortunately fortunately
well you know computer science hard it's
99% perspiration
and the 1% inspiration is really
important but I need the 99 yeah you got
to do a lot of work and then there's
there are interesting things to do at
every level that stack so at the end of
the day if you're on the same program
multiple times does it always produce
the same result is is there some room
for fuzziness there that's a math
problem so if you run a correct C
program the definition is every time you
run it you get the same answer yeah that
well that's a math statement but that's
a that's a language definitional
statement so yes for years when people
did when we first did 3d acceleration of
graphics you could run the same scene
multiple times and get different answers
right right and then some people thought
that was okay and some people thought it
was a bad idea and then when the HPC
world used GPUs for calculations they
thought it's a really bad idea okay now
in modern AI stuff people are looking at
networks where the precision of the data
is low enough that the date has somewhat
noisy and the observation as the input
data is unbelievably noisy so why should
the calculation be not noisy and people
have experimented with algorithms that
say can get faster answers by being
noisy like as the network starts to
converge if you look at the computation
graph it starts out really wide and it
gets narrower and you can say is that
last little bit that important or should
I start to graph on the next rap rev
before we would live all the way down to
the answer right so you can create
algorithms that are noisy now if you're
developing something and every time you
run it you get a different answer it's
really annoying and so most people think
even today every time you run the
program you get the same answer now I
know but the question is that's the
formal definition of a programming
language there is a definition of
languages that don't get the same answer
but people who use those you always want
something because you get a bad answer
and then you're wondering is it because
right
something in your brother because of
this and so everybody wants a little
swish that says no matter what ya do it
deterministically and it's really weird
because almost everything going into
monetary calculations is noisy
so why the answers have to be so clear
it's right so where do you stand by
design computers for people who run
programs so somebody says I want in
deterministic answer like most people
want that can you deliver a
deterministic answer I guess is the
question like when you hopefully sure
that's what people don't realize is you
get a deterministic answer even though
the execution flow is very own
deterministic so if you run this program
a hundred times it never runs the same
way twice ever and the answer it arises
the same in but it gets the same answer
every time it's just just them is just
amazing okay you've achieved in eyes of
many people legend status as a cheap art
architect what design creation are you
most proud of
perhaps because it was challenging
because of its impact or because of the
set of brilliant ideas that that were
involved in well I find that description
odd and I has two small children and I
promise you they think it's hilarious
this question yeah so I dude so I I'm
I'm really interested in building
computers and I've worked with really
really smart people
I'm not unbelievably smart I'm
fascinated by how they go together both
as a as a thing to do and is endeavor
that people do how people in computers
go together yeah like how people think
and build a computer and I find
sometimes that the best computer
architects aren't that interested in
people or the best people managers
aren't that good at designing computers
so the whole stack of human beings is
fascinating so the managers individual
engineers yeah I just I said I realized
after a lot of years of building
computers where you sort of build them
out of the transistors logic gates
functional units come
computational elements that you could
think of people the same way so people
are functional units yes and then you
can think of organizational design it's
a computer architectural problem and
then it's like oh that's super cool
because the people are all different
just like the computation elephants are
all different and they like to do
different things and and so I had a lot
of fun like reframing how I think about
organizations just like with with
computers we were saying execution paths
you can have a lot of different paths
that end up at a at at the same good
destination so what have you learned
about the human abstractions from
individual functional human units to the
broader organization what does it take
to create something special well most
people don't think simple enough all
right so do you know the difference
between a recipe and understanding
there's probably a philosophical
description of this so imagine you can
make a loaf of bread yeah the recipe
says get some flour add some water add
some yeast mix it up let it rise put it
in a pan put it in the oven it's a
recipe right understanding bread you can
understand biology supply chains
you know grain grinders yeast physics
you know thermodynamics like there's so
many levels of understanding there and
then when people build and design things
they frequently are executing some stack
of recipes right and the problem with
that is the recipes all have a limited
scope look if you have a really good
recipe book for making bread it won't
tell you anything about how to make an
omelet right right but if you have a
deep understanding of cooking right then
bread omelets you know sandwich you know
there's there's a different you know way
of viewing everything and most people
when you get to be an expert at
something you know you're you're hoping
to achieve deeper understanding not just
a large set of recipes to go execute
and it's interesting the walk groups of
people because xqt reps apiece is
unbelievably efficient if it's what you
want to do if it's not what you want to
do you're really stuck and and that
difference is crucial and ever and
everybody has a balance of let's say
deeper understanding recipes and some
people are really good at recognizing
when the problem is to understand
something DP deeply that make sense
it totally makes sense does it every
stage of development deep on
understanding on the team needed oh this
goes back to the art versus science
question sure if you constantly unpacked
everything for deeper understanding you
never get anything done right and if you
don't unpack understanding when you need
to you'll do the wrong thing and then at
every juncture like human beings are
these really weird things because
everything you tell them has a million
possible outputs all right and then they
all interact in a hilarious way and then
having some intuition about what you
tell them what you do when do you
intervene when do you not it's it's
complicated all right so it's you know
essentially computationally unsolvable
yeah it's an intractable problem sure
humans are a mess but with deep
understanding do you mean also sort of
fundamental questions of things like
what is a computer or why like think the
why question is why are we even building
this like of purpose or do you mean more
like going towards the fundamental
limits of physics sort of really getting
into the core of the sighs well in terms
of building the computer thinks simple
think a little simpler so common
practice is you build a computer and
then when somebody says I want to make
it 10% faster you'll go in and say
alright I need to make this buffer
bigger and maybe I'll add an ad unit or
you know I have this thing that's three
instructions wide I'm going to make it
four instructions wide and what you see
is each piece gets incrementally more
complicated right
and then at some point you hit this
limit like adding another feature or a
buffer doesn't seem to make it any
faster and then people say well that's
because it's a fundamental limit and
then somebody else to look at it and say
well actually the way you divided the
problem up and the way that different
features are interacting is limiting you
and it has to be rethought rewritten
right so then you refactor it and
rewrite it and what people commonly find
is the rewrite is not only faster but
half is complicated from scratch yes so
how often in your career but just have
you seen as needed maybe more generally
to just throw the whole out thing out
this is where I'm on one end of it every
three to five years which end are you on
like rewrite more often right and three
or five years is if you want to really
make a lot of progress on computer
architecture every five years you should
do one from scratch so where does the
x86 64 standard come in or what how
often do you I wrote the I was the
co-author that's back in 98 that's 20
years ago yeah so that's still around
the instruction set it stuff has been
extended quite a few times yes and
instruction sets are less interesting
and implementation underneath there's
been on x86 architecture Intel's
designed a few Eames is designed a few
very different architectures and I don't
want to go into too much of the detail
about how often but it's there's a
tendency to rewrite it every you know 10
years and it really should be every five
so you're saying you're an outlier in
that sense in really more often we write
more often well in here isn't that scary
yeah of course
well scary - who - everybody involved
because like you said repeating the
recipe is efficient companies want to
make money well no in the individual
juniors want to succeed so you want to
incrementally improve increase the
buffer from three to four well we get
into the diminishing return curves I
think Steve Jobs said this right so
every
you have a project and you start here
and it goes up and they have Domitian
return and to get to the next level you
have to do a new one in the initial
starting point will be lower than the
old optimization point but it'll get
higher so now you have two kinds of fear
short-term disaster and long-term
disaster and you're you're wrong right
like you know people with a quarter by
quarter business objective are terrified
about changing everything yeah and
people who are trying to run a business
or build a computer for a long term
objective know that the short-term
limitations block them from the long
term success so if you look at leaders
of companies that had really good
long-term success every time they saw
that they had to redo something they did
and so somebody has to speak up or you
do multiple projects in parallel like
you optimize the old one while you build
a new one and but the marketing guys
they're always like make promise me that
the new computer is faster on every
single thing and the computer architect
says well the new computer will be
faster on the average but there's a
distribution or results in performance
and you'll have some outliers that are
slower and that's very hard because they
have one customer cares about that one
so speaking of the long-term for over 50
years now
Moore's law has served a for me and
millions of others as an inspiring
beacon what kind of amazing future
brilliant engineers can build no I'm
just making your kids laugh all of today
it was great so first in your eyes what
is Moore's law if you could define for
people who don't know well the simple
statement was from Gordon Moore was
double the number of transistors every
two years something like that and then
my operational model is we increased the
performance of computers by 2x every 2
or 3 years and it's wiggled around
substantially over time and also in how
we deliver performance has changed
but the foundational idea was to X two
transistors every two years the current
cadence is something like they call it a
shrink factor like point six every two
years which is not 0.5 but that that's
referring strictly again to the original
definition of transistor count a shrink
factors just getting them smaller small
as well as you use for a constant chip
area if you make the transistor smaller
by 0.6 then you get 1 over 0.6 more
transistors so can you linger a little
longer what's what's a broader what do
you think should be the broader
definition of Moore's law we mentioned
before how you think of performance just
broadly what's a good way to think about
Moore's law well first of all so I I've
been aware of Moore's law for 30 years
in what sense well I've been designing
computers for 40 just watching it before
your eyes kind of slow and somewhere
where I became aware of it I was also
informed that Moore's law was gonna die
in 10 to 15 years and I thought that was
true at first but then after 10 years it
was gonna die in 10 to 15 years and then
at one point it was gonna die in 5 years
and then it went back up to ten years
and at some point I decided not to worry
about that particular product
mastication for the rest of my life
which is which is fun and then I joined
Intel and everybody said Moore's law is
dead and I thought that's sad because
it's the Moore's law company and it's
not dead and it's always been gonna die
and you know humans you like these
apocryphal kind of statements like we'll
run out of food or run out of air or you
know something right but it's still
incredible this lived for as long as it
has and yes
there's many people who believe now that
Moore's Law instead you know they can
join the last 50 years of people had the
thing yeah there's a long tradition but
why do you think if you can in touch try
to understand it why do you think it's
not dead well for Hartley let's just
think people think Moore's law is one
thing transistors get smaller but
actually under the sheets ours literally
thousands of innovations and almost all
those innovations have their own
diminishing return curves so if you
graph it it looks like a cascade of
diminishing return curves I don't know
what to call that but the result is an
exponential curve at least it has been
so and we keep inventing new things so
if you're an expert in one of the things
on a diminishing return curve right and
you can see it's plateau you will
probably tell people well this is this
is done meanwhile some other pile of
people are doing something different so
that's that's just normal so then
there's the observation of how small
could a switching device be so a modern
transistor is something like a thousand
by a thousand by thousand atoms right
and you get quantum effects down around
two to two to ten atoms so you can
imagine the transistor as small as 10 by
10 by 10 so that's a million times
smaller and then the quantum
computational people are working away at
how to use quantum effects so a thousand
by thousand five thousand atoms it's a
really clean way of putting it well fin
like a modern transistor if you look at
the fan it's like a hundred and twenty
atoms wide but we can make that thinner
and then there's there's a gate wrapped
around it and under spacing there's a
whole bunch of geometry and you know a
competent transistor designer could
count both atoms in every single
direction like there's techniques now to
already put down atoms in a single
atomic layer and you can place atoms if
you want to it's just you know from a
manufacturing process if placing an atom
takes ten minutes and you need to put
you know 10 to the 23rd atoms together
to make a computer it would take a long
time so the the methods are you know
both shrinking things and then coming up
with effective ways to control what's
happening manufacture stabling cheaply
yeah so the innovation stocks pretty
broad you know there
there's equipment there's optics there's
chemistry there's physics there's
material science there's metallurgy
there's lots of ideas about when you put
their four materials together how they
interact are they stable is I stable or
temperature you know like are they
repeatable you know there's look there's
like literally thousands of technologies
involved but just for the shrinking you
don't think we're quite yet close to the
fundamental limit in physics I did a
talk on Moore's Law and I asked for a
road map to a path of 100 and after two
weeks they said we only got to fifty a
hundred what's a 100 extra hundred
shrink we only got 15 I said once you go
to another two weeks well here's the
thing about Moore's law right so I
believe that the next 10 or 20 years of
shrinking is going to happen right now
as a computer designer there's you have
two stances you think it's going to
shrink in which case you're designing
and thinking about architecture in a way
that you'll use more transistors or
conversely not be swamped by the
complexity of all the transistors you
get right you have to have a strategy
you know so you're open to the
possibility and waiting for the
possibility of a whole new army of
transistors ready to work I'm expecting
expecting more transistors every two or
three years by a number large enough
that how you think about design how you
think about architecture has to change
like imagine you're you build built
brick buildings out of bricks and every
year the bricks are half the size or
every two years well if you kept
building bricks the same way you know so
many bricks per person per day the
amount of time to build a building would
go up exponentially right right but if
you said I know that's coming so now I'm
going to design equipment and moves
bricks faster uses them better because
maybe you're getting something out of
the smaller bricks more strengths inner
walls you know less material efficiency
out of that so once you have a roadmap
with what's going to happen transistors
they're gonna get we're gonna get more
of them then you design
was collateral rounded to take advantage
of it and also to cope with it like
that's the thing people to understand
it's like if I didn't believe in Moore's
law and Moore's law transistors showed
up my design teams were all drowned so
what's the what's the hardest part of
this in flood of new transistors I mean
even if you just look historically
throughout your career what's what's the
thing you what fundamentally changes
when you add more transistors in in the
task of designing an architecture no
there's there's two constants right one
is people don't get smarter I think by
the way there's some size shown that we
do get smarter because nutrition
whatever
sorry bring that what effect yes nobody
understands it nobody knows if it's
still going on so that's all or whether
it's real or not but yeah that's a I
sort of Amen but not if I believe for
the most part people aren't getting much
smarter the evidence doesn't support it
that's right and then teams can't grow
that much right all right so human
beings understand you know we're really
good in teams of ten you know up two
teams of a hundred they can know each
other beyond that you have to have
organizational boundaries so you're kind
of you have those are pretty hard
constraints all right so then you have
to divide and conquer like as the
designs get bigger you have to divide it
into pieces you know that the power of
abstraction layers is really high we
used to build computers out of
transistors now we have a team that
turns transistors and logic cells and
our team that turns them into functional
you know it's another one it turns in
computers right so we have abstraction
layers in there and you have to think
about when do you shift gears on that we
also use faster computers to build
faster computers so some algorithms run
twice as fast on new computers but a lot
about rhythms are N squared so you know
a computer with twice as many
transistors and it might take four Tom's
times as long to run so you have to
refactor at the software like simply
using faster computers to build bigger
computers doesn't work so so you have to
think about all these things so in terms
of computing performance and the
exciting possibility that more powerful
computers bring
is shrinking the thing we've been
talking about one of the for you one of
the biggest exciting possibilities of
advancement in performance or is there
are other directions that you're
interested in like like in the direction
of sort of enforcing given parallelism
or like doing massive parallelism in
terms of many many CPUs you know
stacking CPUs on top of each other that
kind of that kind of parallelism or you
kind of well think about it a different
way so old computers you know slow
computers you said a equal B plus C
times D pretty simple right and then we
made faster computers with vector units
and you can do proper equations and
matrices right and then modern like AI
computations or like convolutional
neural networks we you convolve one
large data set against another and so
there's sort of this hierarchy of
mathematics
you know from simple equation to linear
equations to matrix equations to it's a
deeper kind of computation and the data
sets are getting so big that people are
thinking of data as a topology problem
you know data is organized in some
immense shape and then the computation
which sort of wants to be get data from
immense shape and do some computation on
it so the with computers of a lot of
people to do is how about rhythms go
much much further so that that paper you
you reference the Sutton paper they
talked about you know like in a I
started it was a ploy rule sets to
something that's a very simple
computational situation and then when
they did first chess thing they solved
deep searches so have a huge database of
moves and results deep search but it's
still just a search right now we we take
large numbers of images and we use it to
Train these weight sets that we convolve
across it's a completely different kind
of phenomena we call that AI now they're
doing the next generation and if you
look at it they're going up this mathema
graph right and then computations the
both computation and data sets support
going up that graph yeah the kind of
computation of my I mean I would argue
that all of it is still a search right
just like you said a topology problems
data says he's searching the data sets
for valuable data and also the actual
optimization of your networks is a kind
of search for the I don't know if you
looked at the inner layers of finding a
cat it's not a search it's it's a set of
endless projection so you know
projection and here's a shadow of this
phone yeah right then you can have a
shadow of that onto something a shadow
on that or something if you look in the
layers you'll see this layer actually
describes pointy ears and round eyeness
and fuzziness and but the computation to
tease out the attributes is not search
right ain't like the inference part
might be searched but the trainings not
search okay well 10 then in deep
networks they look at layers and they
don't even know it's represented and yet
if you take the layers out it doesn't
work ok so if I don't think it's search
all right well but you have to talk to
my mathematician about what that
actually is oh you disagree but the the
it's just semantics I think it's not but
it's certainly not I would say it's
absolutely not semantics but okay all
right well if you want to go there so
optimization to me is search and we're
trying to optimize the ability of a
neural network to detect cat ears and
this difference between chess and the
space the incredibly multi-dimensional
hundred thousand dimensional space that
you know networks are trying to optimize
over is nothing like the chessboard
database so it's a totally different
kind of thing and okay in that sense you
can say yeah yeah you know I could see
how you you might say if if you the
funny thing is it's the difference
between given search space and found
search space exactly yeah maybe that's a
different way
beautiful but okay but you're saying
what's your sense in terms of the basic
mathematical operations and the
architectures can be hardwired that
enables those operations do you see the
CPUs of today still being a really core
part of executing those mathematical
operations yes
well the operations you know continue to
be add subtract loads or compare and
branch it's it's remarkable so it's it's
interesting that the building blocks of
you know computers or transistors and
you know under that atoms so you got
atoms transistors logic gates computers
right you know functional units and
computers the building blocks of
mathematics at some level are things
like adds and subtracts and multiplies
but that's the space mathematics can
describe is I think essentially infinite
but the computers that run the
algorithms are still doing the same
things now a given algorithm may say I
need sparse data or I need 32-bit data
or I need you know like a convolution
operation that naturally takes 8-bit
data multiplies it and sums it up a
certain way so the like the data types
in tensorflow imply an optimization set
but when you go write down a look at the
computers it's an inorganic salt applies
like like that hasn't changed much
now the quantum researchers think
they're going to change that radically
and then there's people who think about
analog computing because you look in the
brain and it seems to be more analog ish
you know that maybe there's a way to do
that more efficiently but we have a
million acts on computation and I don't
know the reference the relationship
between computational let's say
intensity and ability to hit match
mathematical abstractions I don't know
anyway subscribe dad but but just like
you saw an AI you went from rule sets
the simple search to complex search does
a found search like those are you know
orders of magnitude more computation to
do
and as we get the next two orders of
magnitude your friend Roger godori said
like every order magnitude changed the
computation fundamentally changes what
the computation is doing here oh you
know the expression the difference in
quantity is the difference in kind you
know the difference between ant and ant
hill right or neuron and brain you know
there's there's there's just indefinable
place where the the quantity changed the
quality right now we've seen that happen
in mathematics multiple times and you
know my my guess is it's gonna keep
happening so your senses yeah if you
focus head down and shrinking a
transistor let's not just head down and
we're aware about the software stacks
that are running in the computational
loads and we're kind of pondering what
do you do with a petabyte of memory that
wants to be accessed in a sparse way and
have you know the kind of calculations
ai programmers want so there's that
there's a dialog interaction but when
you go in the computer chip you know you
find adders and subtractors and
multipliers and so if you zoom out then
with as you mentioned which Sutton the
idea that most of the development in the
last many decades in the AI research
came from just leveraging computation
and just the simple algorithms waiting
for the computation to improve well
suffer guys have a thing that they
called the the problem of early
optimization right so if you write a big
software stack and if you start
optimizing like the first thing you
write the odds of that being the
performance limiter is low but when you
get the whole thing working can you make
it to X faster by optimizing the right
things sure while you're optimizing that
could you've written a new software
stack which would have been a better
choice maybe now you have creative
tension so but the whole time as you're
doing the writing the that's the
software we're talking about the
hardware underneath gets faster which
goes back to the Moore's laws Moore's
Law is going to continue then your AI
research
should expect that to show up and then
you make a slightly different set of
choices then we've hit the wall
nothing's gonna happen and from here
it's just us rewriting algorithms like
that seems like a failed strategy for
the last 30 years of Moore's laws death
so so can you just linger on it I think
you've answered it but it just asked the
same dumb question over and over so what
why do you think Moore's law is not
going to die which is the most promising
exciting possibility of why it won't
done that's five 10 years so is it that
continues shrinking the transistor or is
it another s-curve that steps in and it
totally so dope shrinking the transistor
is literally thousands of innovations
right so there's so this they're all
answers and it's there's a whole bunch
of s-curves just kind of running their
course and being reinvented and new
things you know the the semiconductor
fabricators and technologists have all
announced what's called nano wires so
they they took a fan which had a gate
around it and turned that into a little
wire so you have better control that and
they're smaller and then from there
there's some obvious steps about how to
shrink that so the metallurgy around
wire stocks and stuff has very obvious
abilities to shrink and you know there's
a whole combination of things there to
do your sense is that we're gonna get a
lot yes this innovation from just that
shrinking yeah like a factor of a
hundred salade yeah I would say that's
incredible and it's totally it's only 10
or 15 years now you're smarter you might
know but to me it's totally
unpredictable of what that hundred x
would bring in terms of the nature of
the computation and people be yeah you
familiar with Bell's law so for a long
time those mainframes
Mini's workstation PC mobile Moore's Law
drove faster smaller computers right and
then we were thinking about Moore's law
rajae godori said every 10x generates a
new computation so scalar vector made
Erichs topological computation right and
if you go look at the industry trans
there was no mainframes and
mini-computers and PCs and then the
internet took off and then we got mobile
devices and now we're building 5g
wireless with one millisecond latency
and people are starting to think about
the smart world where everything knows
you recognizes you like like like the
transformations are going to be like
unpredictable how does it make you feel
that you're one of the key architects of
this kind of futures you're not we're
not talking about the architects of the
high-level people who build the Angry
Bird apps and flapping
Angry Bird of who knows we're gonna be
that's the whole point of the universe
let's take a stand at that and the
attention distracting nature of mobile
phones I'll take a stand but anyway in
terms of that matters much the the side
effects of smartphones or the attention
distraction which part well who knows
you know where this is all leading it's
changing so fast wax my parents do steal
my sister's for hiding in the closet
with a wired phone with a dial on it
stop talking your friends all day right
now my wife feels with my kids for
talking to their friends all day on text
looks the same to me it's always it's
echoes of the same thing okay but you
are the one of the key people
architecting the hardware of this future
how does that make you feel do you feel
responsible do you feel excited so we're
we're in a social context so there's
billions of people on this planet there
are literally millions of people working
on technology I feel lucky to be you
know what doing what I do and getting
paid for it and there's an interest in
it but there's so many things going on
in parallel it's like the actions are so
unpredictable if I wasn't here somebody
else are doing the the vectors of all
these different things are happening all
the time you know there's a
I'm sure some philosopher or meta
philosophers you know wondering about
how we transform our world so you can't
deny the fact that these tools whether
that these tools are changing our world
that's right do you think it's changing
for the better so some of these I read
this thing recently it said the peat the
two disciplines with the highest GRE
scores in college are physics in
philosophy right and they're both sort
of trying to answer the question why is
there anything right and the
Philosopher's you know are on the kind
of theological side and the physicists
are obviously on the you know the
material side and there's a hundred
billion galaxies with a hundred billion
stars it seems well repetitive at best
so I you know there's on our way to ten
billion people I mean it's hard to say
what it's all for is that's what you're
asking
yeah I guess I guess I do tend to are
significantly increases in complexity
and I'm curious about how computation
like like our world our physical world
inherently generates mathematics it's
kind of obvious right so we have X Y Z
coordinates you take a sphere you make
it bigger you get a surface that falls
you know grows by r-squared like it
generally generates mathematics and the
mathematicians and the physicists have
been having a lot of fun talking to each
other for years and computation has been
let's say relatively pedestrian like
computation in terms of mathematics has
been doing binary binary algebra while
those guys have been gallivanting
through the other realms of possibility
right now recently the computation lets
you do math m'q mathematical
computations that are sophisticated
enough that nobody understands how the
answers came out right machine learning
machine lying yeah it used to be you get
data set you guess at a function the
function is considered physics if it's
predictive of new functions
data sets modern you can take a large
data set with no intuition about what it
is and use machine learning to find a
pattern that has no function right and
it can arrive at results that I don't
know if they're completely
mathematically describable so a
computation is kind of done something
interesting compared to a POV plus see
there's something reminiscent of that
step from the basic operations of
addition to taking a step towards new
all networks that's reminiscent of what
life on Earth and its origins was doing
do you think we're creating sort of the
next step in our evolution in creating
artificial intelligence systems that I
don't know I mean you know if there's so
much in the universe already it's hard
to say well I'm standing in his hold are
human beings working on additional
abstraction layers and possibilities yet
appear so does that mean that human
beings don't need dogs you know no like
like there's so many things that are all
simultaneously interesting and useful
but you've seen through I agree you've
seen great and greater level
abstractions and built in artificial
machines right do you think when you
look at humans you think that the look
of all life on earth as a single
organism building this thing this
machine that greater and greater levels
of abstraction do you think humans are
the peak the top of the food chain in
this long arc of history on earth or do
you think we're just somewhere in the
middle are we are we the basic
functional operations of a CPU are we
the C++ program the Python Perl Network
like somebody's you know people have
calculated like how many operations does
the brain do and something you know I've
seen the number 10 to the 18th about
bunch of times arrive different ways so
could you make a computer that did 10 to
the 20th operations yes sure do you
think we're gonna do that now is there
something magical about how brains
compute things I don't know you know my
personal experiences
interesting cuz you know you think you
know how you think and then you have all
these ideas and you can't figure out how
they happened and if you meditate you
know the like what what you can be aware
of is interesting so I don't know if
brains are magical or not you know the
physical evidence says no lots of
people's personal experiences yes so
what would be funny as if brains are
magical and yet we can make brains with
more computation you know I don't know
what to say about that but what do you
think magic is an emergent phenomena
what would be our than me I don't know
teller of what what what in your view is
consciousness with with consciousness
yeah like what you know cautiousness
love things that are these deeply human
things that seems to emerge from our
brain is that something that we'll be
able to make encode in chips that get
faster and faster and faster and faster
the flick of 10 our conversations no but
nobody really knows can you summarize it
in a couple of couple of words many
people have observed that organisms run
at lots of different levels right if you
got two neurons somebody said you'd have
one sensory neuron and one motor neuron
right so we move towards things and away
from things and we have physical
integrity and safety or not right and
then if you look at the animal kingdom
you can see brains that are a little
more complicated and at some point
there's a planning system and then
there's an emotional system that's you
know happy about being safe or unhappy
about being threatened right and then
our brains have massive numbers of
structures you know like planning and
movement and thinking and feeling and
drives and emotions and we seem to have
multiple layers of thinking systems and
we have a brain a dream system that
nobody understands whatsoever which I
find completely hilarious and you can
think in a way that those systems are
more independent and you can observe you
know the different parts of yourself can
observe
I don't know which one's magical I don't
know which ones not computational so is
it possible that it's all computation
probably is there a limit to computation
I don't think so
do you think the universe is a computer
I think he seems to be it's a weird kind
of computer because if it was a computer
right like when they do calculations on
what it how much calculation it takes to
describe quantum effects is unbelievably
high so if it was a computer when you
built it out of something that was
easier to compute right that's that's a
funny
it's a funny system but then the
simulation guys have pointed out that
the rules are kind of interesting like
when you look really close it's
uncertain and the speed of light says
you could only look so far and things
can't be simultaneous except for the odd
entanglement problem where they seem to
be like the rules are all kind of weird
and somebody said physics is like having
50 equations with 50 variables to define
50 variables like you know it's it's you
know like physics itself has been a
shitshow for thousands of years it seems
odd when you get to the corners of
everything you know it's either
uncomputable or on definable or
uncertain it's almost like the designers
the simulation are trying to prevent us
from understanding it perfectly but but
also the things that require
calculations requires so much
calculation that our idea of the
universe of a computer is absurd because
every single little bit of it takes all
the computation in the universe to
figure out gee that's a weird kind of
computer you know you say the simulation
is running in the computer which has by
definition infinite computations not
infinite
oh you mean if the universe is infinite
yeah piece of our universe seems to take
infinite computation I hit you're out
just a lot whoa a lot some pretty big
number compute this little teeny spot
takes all the mass in the local one
little year by one like your space it's
close enough to infinite so it's a heck
of a computer if it is one I know it's
it's it's a weird it's a weird
description because the simulations
description seems too
the break when you look closely at it
but the rules in universe seemed to
imply something's up that seems a little
arbitrary the whole the universe the
whole thing the the laws of physics you
know it just seems like like how did it
come out to be yeah the way it is but
lots of people talk about that it's you
know it's like I said the two smartest
groups of humans are working on the same
problem different different aspects and
they're both complete failures so that's
kind of cool
they might succeed eventually well after
two thousand years the trend isn't good
two thousand years is nothing in the
span of the history of the universe so
we have some time but the next thousand
years doesn't look good either so that's
what everybody says that every stage but
with Moore's law as you've just
described not being dead the exponential
growth the technology the future seems
pretty incredible well it'll be
interesting that's for sure that's right
so what are your thoughts on Ray
Kurzweil sense that exponential
improvement and technology will continue
indefinitely that is that how you see
Moore's law do you see Moore's law more
broadly and since the technology of all
kinds has a way of stacking s curves on
top of each other where it'll be
exponential and then we'll see all kinds
of what was an exponential of a million
mean that's that's a pretty amazing
number and that's just for a local
little piece of silicon now it's imagine
you say decided to get a thousand tons
of silicon to collaborate in one
computer at a million times the density
like now you know you're talking I don't
know 10 to the 20th more computation
power then our current already
unbelievably fast computers like nobody
knows what that's going to mean you know
the sci-fi guys called you know
computron 'i'm like when like a local
civilization turns the nearby star into
a computer I like I don't that's true
but so just even when you shrink a
transistor the that's only one dimension
of the ripple effects of that but people
tend to think about computers
the cost problem right so computers are
made out of silicon and minor amounts of
metals and you know this and that none
of those things cost any money like
there's plenty of sand like like you
could just turn the beach and a little
bit ocean water in the computers so all
the cost is and equipment to do it
and the trend on equipment is once you
figure out a build the equipment the
trend of cost is zero Elon said first
you figure out what configuration you
want the atoms in and then how to put
them there right yeah
cuz well what here's you know his his
great insight is people are how
constrained I have this thing I know how
it works and then little tweaks to that
will generate something as opposed to
what do I actually want and then figure
out how to build it it's a very
different mindset and almost nobody has
it obviously well let me ask on that
topic you were one of the key early
people in the development of autopilot
at least in the hardware side Elon Musk
believes that autopilot and vehicle
autonomy if you just look at that
problem can follow this kind of
exponential improvement in terms of the
ha the how question that we're talking
about there's no reason why I can't what
are your thoughts on this particular
space of vehicle autonomy and you're a
part of it and Elon Musk's and Tesla's
vision well the computer you need to
build was straightforward and you can
argue well doesn't need to be 2 times
faster or 5 times or 10 times but that's
just a matter of time or price in the
short run so that's that's not a big
deal you don't have to be especially
smart to drive a car so it's not like a
super hard problem I mean the big
problem with safety is attention which
computers are really good at not skills
well let me push back on one you see
everything you said it's correct but we
as humans tend to tend to take for
granted how how incredible our vision
system is so you can drive a car of 2050
vision
and you can train a neural network to
extract a distance of any object in the
shape of any surface from a video and
data but that really simple not simple I
look that's a simple data problem it's
not it's not simple it's because you
because it's not just detecting object
it's understanding the scene and it's
being able to do it in a way that
doesn't make errors so the beautiful
thing about the human vision system and
the entire brain around the whole thing
is we were able to fill in the gaps it's
not just about perfectly detecting cars
it's inferring the occluded cars it's
trying to it's it's understanding the I
think it's mostly a bigger problem you
so you think what data you know with
compute with improvement of computation
with improvement in collection well
there is a you know when you're driving
a car and somebody cuts you off your
brain has theories about why they did it
you know they're a bad person they're
distracted they're dumb you know you can
listen to yourself
right so you know if you think that
narrative is important to be able to
successfully drive a car then current
autopilot systems can't do it but if
cars are ballistic things with tracks
and probabilistic changes of speed and
direction and roads are fixed and given
by the way they don't change dynamically
right you can map the world really
thoroughly you can place every object
really thoroughly right you can
calculate trajectories of things really
thoroughly right but everything you said
about really thoroughly has a different
degree of difficulty so you could say at
some point computer autonomous systems
will be way better it's things that
humans are allows yet like it'll be
better at abstention they'll always
remember there was a pothole in the road
that humans keep forgetting about
they'll remember that this set of roads
how these weirdo lines on it the
computers figured out once and
especially if they get updates so if
somebody changes a given like that Akita
robots and stuff somebody said is to
maximize two Givens
okay right so though having a robot pick
up this bottle cap is ways you put a red
dot on the top because then you have to
figure out you know if you want to do a
certain thing with it you know maximize
the Givens is the thing and autonomous
systems are happily maximizing the
Givens like humans when you drive
someplace new you remember it because
you're processing it the whole time and
after the 50th time you drove to work
you get to work you don't know how you
got there right you're on autopilot
right autonomous cars are always on
autopilot but the cars have no theories
about why they got cut off or why
they're in traffic so they'll never stop
paying attention right so I tend to
believe you do have deaf theories mental
models of other people especially
pedestrians cyclists but also with other
cars everything you said is like is
actually essential to driving driving is
a lot more complicated than people
realize I think so sort of to push back
slightly but cut into traffic right yeah
you can't just wait for a gap you have
to be somewhat aggressive you'd be
surprised how simple a calculation for
that is I may be on that particular
point but there's a that it may be asked
you to push back I would be surprised
you know what yeah I'll just say where I
stand I would be very surprised but I
think it's you might be surprised how
complicated it is that I'd say that I
tell people's like progress disappoints
in the short run the surprises in the
long run it's very possible yeah I
suspect in 10 years it'll be just like
taken for granted yeah but you're
probably right now look like it's gonna
be a $50 solution that nobody cares
about like GPS is like wow GPS is we
have satellites in space that tell you
where your location is it was a really
big deal now everything is the GPS I
mean yeah it's true but I do think that
systems that involve human behavior are
more complicated than we give them
credit for so we can do incredible
things with technology that don't
involve humans but when you look humans
are less complicated than people you
know frequently obscure I've maybe I
stand off right out of large numbers of
patterns and just keep doing it over
but I can't trust you because you're a
human that's something something a human
would say but I might my hope was on the
point you've made is even if no matter
who is right Eve there I'm hoping that
there's a lot of things that humans
aren't good at that machines are
definitely good I like you said
attention and things like that well
they'll be so much better that the
overall picture of safety in autonomy
will be obviously cars will be safer
even if they're not as good I'm a big
believer in safety I mean there are
already the current safety systems like
cruise control that doesn't let you run
into people and lane-keeping there are
so many features that you just look at
the pareto of accidents and knocking off
like 80% of them you know super doable
just a wing guard on the autopilot team
and the efforts there the it seems to be
that there's a very intense scrutiny by
the media and the public in terms of
safety the pressure the bar but before
autonomous vehicles what are your sort
of as a person they're working on the
hardware and trying to build a system
that builds a safe vehicle and so on
what was your sense about that pressure
is it unfair is it expected of new
technology it seems reasonable I was
interested I talked to both American and
European regulators and I was worried
that the regulations would write into
the rules technology solutions like
modern brake systems imply hydraulic
brakes so if you'll read the regulations
to meet the letter of the law for brakes
it sort of has to be hydraulic right and
the regulator said there they're
interested in the use cases like a
head-on crash an offset crash don't hit
pedestrians don't run into people don't
leave the road don't run a red light or
a stop light they were very much into
the scenarios and you know and they had
they had all the data about which
scenarios injured or killed to most
people and for the most part those
conversations were like what's the right
thing to do to take the next step
now elan is very interested also in the
benefits of autonomous driving or
freeing people's time and attention as
well as safety and I think that's also
an interesting thing but you know
building an autonomous system so they're
safe and safer and people seemed since
the goals to be tannic seifer's and
people having the bar to be safer than
people and scrutinizing accidents seems
philosophically you know correct so I
think that's a good thing
what R is is different than the things
you've worked at new Intel AMD apple
with autopilot chip design and hardware
design what are interesting or
challenging aspects of building this
specialized kind of competing system in
the automotive space I mean there's two
tricks to building like an automotive
computer one is to software our team the
machine learning team is developing
algorithms that are changing fast
so as you're building the the
accelerator you have this you know worry
or intuition that the algorithms will
change enough that the accelerator will
be the wrong one right and there's the
generic thing which is if you build a
really good general-purpose computers
hey it's performance is one and then GPU
guys will deliver about 5x to
performance for the same amount of
silicon because instead of discovering
parallelism you're given parallelism and
then special accelerators get another
two to five X on top of a GPU because
you say I know the math is always 8-bit
integers and two 32-bit accumulators and
the operations are the subsets of
mathematical possibilities so although
you know AI accelerators have a claimed
performance benefit over GPUs because in
the narrow math space you're nailing the
algorithm now you still try to make it
programmable but the AI field is
changing really fast so there's a you
know there's little creative tension era
of I want the acceleration afforded by
specialization without being over
specialized
so that the new algorithm is so much
more effective that you'd have been
better off on a GPU so there's attention
there to build a good computer for an
application like automotive there's all
kinds of sensor inputs and safety
processors and a bunch of stuff so one
of loans goal is to make it super
affordable so every car gets an
autopilot computer so some of the recent
startups you look at and they have a
server in the trunk because they're
saying I'm going to build this autopilot
computer replaces the driver so their
cost budgets ten or twenty thousand
dollars and eelain's constraint was I'm
gonna put one every in every car whether
people buy autonomous driving or not so
the cost constraint he had in mind was
great right and to hit that you had to
think about the system design that's
complicated it's it's fun you know it's
like it's like it's craftsmen's work
like a violin maker right you could say
Stradivarius is this incredible thing
the musicians are incredible but the guy
making the violin you know picked wood
and sanded it and then he cut it you
know and he glued it and you know and he
waited for the right day so that when
you put the finish on it didn't you know
do something dumb
that's craftsmen's work right you may be
a genius craftsman because you have the
best techniques and you discover a new
one but most engineers craftsmen's work
and humans really like to do that you
know smart humans oh no everybody oh I
know I used to I dug ditches when I was
in college I got really good at it
satisfying yeah so digging ditches is
also craft malware yeah of course
so so there's an expression called
complex mastery behavior so when you're
learning something that's fun because
you're learning something when you do
something that's wrote and simple it's
not that satisfying but if the steps
that you have to do or complicate it and
you're good at them it's satisfying to
do them and then if you're intrigued by
it all as you're doing them you
sometimes learn new things that you can
raise your game but Christmas work is
good
in engineers like engineering is
complicated enough that you have to
learn a lot of skills and then a lot of
what you do is then craftsmen's work
which is fun autonomous driving building
a very
a resource-constrained computer so
computer has to be cheap enough that put
in every single car that's essentially
boils down to craftsmen's work it's
saying genius so there's thoughtful
decisions and problems to solve and
trade-offs to make do you need 10
Cameron ports or 8 you know you're
building for the current car or the next
one you know how do you do the safety
stuff you know there's there's a whole
bunch of details but it's fun but it's
not like I'm building a new type and
they're all networked which has a new
mathematics and a new computer at work
do you know that that's like there's a
there's more invention than that but the
rejection to practice once you picked
the architecture you look inside and
what do you see
adders and multipliers and memories and
you know the basics so computers is
always just this weird set of
abstraction layers of ideas and thinking
that reduction to practice is
transistors and wires and you know
pretty basic stuff and that's an
interesting phenomena by the way that
like factory work like lots of people
think factory work is Road assembly
stuff I've been on the assembly line
like the people work that really liked
it it's a really great job it's really
complicated putting cars together is
hard right and in the cars moving and
the parts are moving and sometimes the
parts are damaged and you have to
coordinate putting all the stuff
together and people are good at it
they're good at it and I remember one
day I went to work and the line was shut
down for some reason and then some of
the guys sitting around were really
bummed because they they had reorganized
a bunch of stuff and they were gonna hit
a new record for the number of cars
built that day and they were all gung ho
to do it and these were big tough
buggers yeah you know but what they did
was complicated and you couldn't do it
yeah and I mean well after a while you
could but you'd have to work your way up
cuz you know like putting a bright
what's called the bright stuff at the
trim on a car
on a moving assembly line where it has
to be attached 25 places in a minute and
a half is unbelievably complicated and
and and human beings can do it's really
good
I think that's harder than driving a car
by the way putting together working
working on the factory to smart
people can disagree yeah I think drive
driving a car will get you in the
factory something will see you're not
for us humans driving a car is easy I'm
saying building a machine that drives a
car is not easy
ok ok driving a car is easy for humans
because we've been evolving for billions
of years
drive cars yeah no juice the pail if the
cars are super cool no now you join the
rest of the internet and mocking me ok
yeah yeah intrigued by your you know
your anthropology yeah it says we have
to go dig into that there's some
inaccuracies there yes ok but in general
what have you learned in terms of
thinking about passion craftsmanship
tension chaos you know the whole mess of
it or what have you learned have taken
away from your time working with Elon
Musk working at Tesla which is known to
be a place of chaos innovation
craftsmanship and I really like the way
he thought like you think you have an
understanding about what first
principles of something is and then you
talk to you alone about it and you you
didn't scratch the surface you know he
has a deep belief that no matter what
you do is a local maximum right
I had a friend he invented a better
electric motor and it was like a lot
better than what we were using and one
day he came by he said you know I'm a
little disappointed cuz you know this is
really great and you didn't seem that
impressed and I said you know and the
super intelligent aliens come are they
gonna be looking for you like where is
he the guy you built the motor yeah
probably not you know like like the but
doing interesting work that's both
innovative and let's say craftsmen's
work on the current thing it's really
satisfying it's good and and that's cool
and then Elon was good taking everything
apart and like what's the deep first
principle oh no what's really
what's really you know you know you know
that that you know ability to look at it
without assumptions and and how
constraints is super wild you know we
build rocket ship and using the same car
you know everything and that's super fun
and he's into it too like when they
first landed to SpaceX Rockets at Tesla
we had a video projector in the big room
and like five hundred people came down
and when they landed everybody cheered
and some people cried it was so cool
alright but how did you do that well it
was super hard and then people say well
it's chaotic really to get out of all
your assumptions you think that's not
going to be unbelievably painful and
there's Elon tough yeah probably the
people look back on it and say boy I'm
really happy I had that experience to go
take apart that many layers of
assumptions
sometimes super fun sometimes painful so
it could be emotionally and
intellectually painful that whole
process just stripping away assumptions
yeah I imagine 99% of your thought
process is protecting your self
conception and 98% of that's wrong yeah
now you got there math right no you
think your feeling when you get back
into that one bit that's useful and now
you're open and you have the ability to
do something different I don't know if I
got the math right it might be ninety
nine point nine but in 850 imagining it
the 50% is hard enough yeah now for a
long time I've suspected you could get
better look you can think better you can
think more clearly you can take things
apart and there's lots of examples of
that people who do that so any line is
an example of that parent or an example
says you know if I am I'm fun to talk to
certainly I've learned a lot of stuff
right well here's the other thing it's
like I talk like like I read books and
people think oh you read books well no I
brought a couple books
awake for 55 years
well maybe 50 cuz I didn't read learned
read tall as H or something and and it
turns out when people write books they
often take 20 years of their life where
they passionately did something reduce
it to to 200 pages that's kind of fun
and then the goat you go online and you
can find out who wrote the best books
and who like you know that's kind of
Alda so there's this wild selection
process and then you can read it and for
the most part to understand it and then
you can go apply it like I went to one
company and I thought I haven't managed
much before so I read 20 management
books and I started talking to him
basically compared to all the VP's
running around I'd run night read 19
more management books than anybody else
was it even that hard
yeah and a half the stuff worked like
first time it wasn't even rocket science
but at the core of that is questioning
the assumptions okay sort of entering
the thinking first principles thinking
sort of looking at the reality of the
situation and using it using that
knowledge applying that knowledge so
mean yes so I would say my brain has
this idea that you can question first
assumptions and but I can go days at a
time and forget that and you have to
kind of like circle back data
observation because it is because part
Allen gene well it's hard to keep it
front and center because you know you're
you operate on so many levels all the
time and you know getting this done
takes priority or you know being happy
takes priority or you know screwing
around takes priority like like like how
you go through life it's complicated
yeah and then you remember oh yeah I
could really I think first principles so
much [ __ ] that's that's tiring you know
what you do for a while that's kind of
cool so just as the last question your
sense from the big picture from the
first principles do you think you kind
of answered already but do you think
autonomous driving something we can
solve on a timeline of years so
one two three five ten years as opposed
to a century yeah definitely just to
linger and a little longer
where's the confidence coming from is it
the fundamentals of the problem the
fundamentals of building a hardware and
the software as a computational problem
understanding ballistics roles
topography it seems pretty solvable I
mean and you can see this you know like
like speech recognition for a long time
people are doing you know frequency and
domain analysis and and all kinds of
stuff and that didn't work for at all
right and then they did deep learning
about it and it worked great and it took
multiple iterations and you know time is
driving his way past the frequency
analysis point you know use radar don't
run into things and the data gathering
is going up in the computations going up
and the algorithm understanding is going
up and there's a whole bunch of problems
getting solved like that the data side
is really powerful but I disagree with
both you and you and I'll tell you and
once again as I did before that that
when you add human beings into the
picture the it's no longer a ballistics
problem it's something more complicated
but I could be very well proven cars are
hardly damped in terms are ready to
change like the steering and the
steering systems really slow compared to
a computer the acceleration of the
acceleration is really slow yeah on a
certain time scale on a ballistics time
scale but human behavior I don't know it
yeah I shouldn't say it beans are really
slow to weed weirdly we operate
you know half a second behind reality
nobody really understands that one
either it's pretty funny
yeah yeah so no I will be with very well
could be surprised and I think with the
rate of improvement in all aspects I'm
both the computed in the the the
software and the hardware there's gonna
be pleasant surprises all over the place
speaking of unpleasant surprises many
people have worries about a singularity
in the development of AI
forgive me for such questions you know
what when AI improves exponentially and
reaches a point of superhuman level
general intelligence you know beyond the
point there's no looking back do you
share this worry of existential threats
from artificial intelligence from
computers becoming superhuman level
intelligent no not really
you know like we already have a very
stratified society and then if you look
at the whole animal kingdom of
capabilities and abilities and interests
and you know smart people have their
niche and you know normal people have
their niche and craftsmen's have their
niche and you know animals have their
niche I suspect that the domains of
interest for things that you know
astronomically different like the whole
something got 10 times smarter than us
and wanted to track us all down because
what we like to have coffee at Starbucks
like it doesn't seem plausible no is
there an existential problem that how do
you live in a world where there's
something way smarter than you and you
you based your kind of self-esteem on
being the smartest local person well
there's what 0.1% of the population who
thinks that because the rest of the
populations been dealing with it since
they were born
so the the breadth of possible
experience that can be interesting is
really big and you know super
intelligence seems likely although we
still don't know if we're magical but I
suspect we're not and it seems likely
that'll create possibilities that are
interesting for us and it's its
interests will be interesting for that
for whatever it is it's not obvious why
it's interest would somehow want to
fight over some square foot of dirt or
you know whatever then you know the
usual fears are about so you don't think
you'll inherit some of the darker
aspects of human nature depends on how
you think reality is constructed so for
for whatever reasons human beings are
and that's a creative tension in
opposition with both are good and
bad forces like there's lots of
philosophical understandings of that
right I don't know why that would be
different so you think the evils is
necessary for the good I mean the
tension I don't know about evil but like
we live in a competitive world where
your good is somebody else's you know
evil you know there's there's the
malignant part of it but that seems to
be self-limiting although occasionally
it's it's super horrible but yeah look
there's a debate over ideas and some
people have different beliefs and that
that debate itself is a process so the
at arriving at something you know I
wouldn't continue yeah just you but you
don't think that whole process will
leave humans behind in a way that's
painful
an emotionally painful yes for the one
for the point one percent they'll be
there why isn't it already painful for a
large percentage of the population and
it is I mean Society does have a lot of
stress in it about the 1% and the bath
of this and about to that but you know
everybody has a lot of stress in their
life about what they find satisfying and
and you know know yourself seems to be
the proper dictum and pursue something
that makes your life meaningful seems
proper and there's so many avenues on
that like there's so much unexplored
space at every single level
you know I'm somewhat of my nephew
called me a jaded optimist you know so
it's there's a beautiful tension that in
that label but if you were to look back
at your life and could relive a moment a
set of moments because there were the
happiest times in your life outside of
family what would that be I don't want
to relive any moments I like that I like
that situation where you have some
amount of optimism and then
the anxiety of the unknown so you love
the unknown do you the mystery of it I
don't know about the mystery it sure
gets your blood pumping what do you
think is the meaning of this whole thing
of life on this pale blue dot it seems
to be what it does like the universe for
whatever reason makes atoms which makes
us which we do stuff and we figure out
things and we explore things and that's
just what it is
it's not just yeah it is you know Jim I
don't think there's a better place to
end it it's a huge honor and well super
fun thank you so much for talking today
all right great
thanks for listening to this
conversation and thank you to our
presenting sponsor cash app downloaded
use code Lex podcasts you'll get ten
dollars and ten dollars will go to first
a stem education nonprofit that inspires
hundreds of thousands of young minds to
become future leaders and innovators if
you enjoy this podcast subscribe on
YouTube
give it five stars an apple podcast
follow on Spotify supported on patreon
or simply connect with me on Twitter and
now let me leave you with some words of
wisdom from Gordon Moore for everything
you try works you aren't trying hard
enough
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you